meine seele und herz willkommen zu einem
neuen video quasi breaking news heute
ich hab ja eben schon ein anderes video
aufgenommen und umgeschnitten dakar
maximal zwei dicke dinger du musst dir
das reinziehen baby hat beim quiz duell
eingeschossen
was wie ich habe gar nichts davon
mitbekommen das bild überhaupt der
künstler ist aber dort jetzt habe ich
der guten alten zeiten wählen wo ich den
ein oder anderen klick auf bewiesen
angemacht habe für mein schnitt beendet
und schaue mir jetzt blind den kristin
fei von bibiani tag das video auf
twitter gesehen
jemand hat dazu geschrieben in florenz
punkt vom punkt also im westen quasi für
uns influenza stellvertretend stellung
dazu beziehen daher machen wir das
eigentlich auch oder hast du irgendwann
hintergrund ja nee also es geht mir
nicht darum was jetzt kriegt man ja
deshalb gucke mir das einfach mal an und
ich habe schon gesehen ich bin wirklich
sehr gespannt was für alle erste
reaktion ist jetzt dafür also braucht ja
unterschiedliche mengen von kraftstoff
und das macht eine klappe die drosselt
die drosselklappe ist auf jeden fall
richtig
ja also es tritt quasi eine influenza
team gegen ein anderes team also das so
der sinn dieser folge waldgut
drosselklappe okay kann man schon mal
wissen was gibt es offensichtlich nach
analyse von nasa messdaten
natürlicherweise auf dem mars was gibt
es auch das kind nach einer analyse von
semester in natürlicher weise auf dem
mars ok wlan fußbodenheizung www dazu
der früheste genommen hat dann also klar
alle logischerweise ist so fließt das
wasser liegt am nächsten
weil wähler gut fußboden alles lösbar
also wirklich gar nicht ich kenne mich
damit gar nicht aus aber ich hatte jetzt
wlan genommen
schloss stoff schluss bevor dort wo die
erklärung werde ich sehr plausibel war
das natürlicherweise wie viele
handwerker sogar ohne wird ich habe
jetzt noch so eine öko zeitschrift
geleert und die empfehle auch dass man
nur noch natürliches wlan kann das sind
nicht mehr dabei
das ist einfach besser für die geräte
deswegen haben wir auch diese maß sonne
aber ich habe bestimmt dass sie
natürlich wieder an format auf die erde
bringen
wie mache ich was mich denn wir haben
vor gar nicht allzu langer zeit eine
anzeige internet gefunden wo man
angeblich sich ein grundstück auf dem
mars ja aber das war ja was ist und
denkt doch kein
das ist aber auch eine geile verbindung
so von von dummheit und größenwahn wird
ja wir wollten ein grundstück auf dem
mars kaufen
da heißt es mal die immobilienmakler
gehört dass du das selbst das lager
objekt ist dementsprechend gibt es ja
wahrscheinlich auch natürliches mail an
das haben wir ungefähr vor zehn monaten
gesehen hat läuft es um den ersten april
haben mit dieser anzeige gelesen bitte
die wie du bist so mit das gesicht von
youtube deutschland
das kannst du nicht machen das kannst du
nicht machen
natürlich ist weiter wegen so einer
scheiße muss ich mir sprüche ohne
deswegen so als habe ich vor mir
gegenüber dass youtube hängengeblieben
sind ich weiß aber da stand das darin
stand der welt was würde das hast du
gelesen wobei eine person so richtig
hart zu kaum zu bleiben das kann ich
nicht gehört haben weil das geht nicht
nicht niemals jörg pilawa ist einer der
das kurz davor angreifen
also wahrscheinlich ist eine spaß an
zeige aber es gibt uns geholfen
im internet wo man sich eine villa auf
dem mars kaufen kann das stimmt 890
millionen kostet die ja ich würde sagen
ein sehr risikobehaftet das geschäft
weil es ist ja noch nicht mal sicher ob
man den markt bewohnen kann die ersten
häuser rät überhaupt entstehen
wahrscheinlich so in vier und tritt auf
dem platz so gut wie nimmt einfach zwei
jahre sind genug und kein roboter
millionen belaufen
weil leute standortfaktor natürliches
wlan also ich glaube auf der erde sind
die bedingungen nicht so gut dafür dass
die natürlichen netzwerk und erwachsene
von der atmosphäre also man muss
verständnis auch die situation klar also
ist jetzt fernsehen dies scheint nicht
so auf dem fernsehmann ist auf gerät
also ich tue doch nicht so als wenn sie
eine maschine wird alles perfekt machen
kann man kann fehler machen ja aber das
ist schon das ist schon echt bitter wir
kommen mit das balancing schon so falsch
dass ich jetzt auch
ich gebe euch 10 sieg oder wie ich
gespannt wie das ausgeht
wie kann man so leute die versprechen
die sind niemals so dumm sind aber er
gibt ihr auch direkt so die zeit rein
und setzt diese unter der das ja auch
schön falsch waren gleich schlitzer ach
so jetzt aber doch jetzt gesagt ja ja ja
natürlich das paket bald warum wird man
es dann raus
das einzige was mir vorstellen kann dass
das dass sie irgendwie gebeten wurden
falsch zu antworten damit die sendung
irgendwie in eine gewisse richtung gehe
aber du musst was man auch sagen was
steht aktuell 12 09 für den freund sehr
gut
ja aber ich habe auch gesehen unter den
post das davor scheinbar die meisten
fragen so zu rtl
das völlig sowohl der block 3 ist das
falsch ich gebe alles falsch wlan habt
ihr genommen
du hast fließend wasser genommen und gab
es jetzt analysen gemacht nicht von den
wählern
das kann ich es kann nicht sein das kann
nicht sein da kann man nicht so das
zitat vom leiter des planeten programms
unter bestimmten gegebenheiten wurde
fließendes wasser auf dem mars gefunden
blüm presse natürliches wehleidiger ist
doch ganz klar das fließende wasser ist
die richtige antwort
leute lasst uns doch mal auf der zunge
zergehen natürliches wlan auf dem mars
muss mir einen kopfschuss geben an der
stelle
vielleicht kann man es selber von den
das war war die sendung des skriptes
also die auf revanche wir wünschen ja
weil wir nichts schlechtes das ist dafür
irgendeine gute triftige erklärung gibt
das was wir aktuell das thema ganz kurz
die action von uns beiden china festigen
so weit ich habe euch wenn ihr mal
schauen wollt hier noch einsparen das
video verlinkt ach ja und wenn ihr auch
eine portion natürliches weder eine
antwort dann abonniert diesen kanal